[Music]
[Music]
mad flavor here look at this [ __ ]
beauty 8:00 in the morning change
smoking cigarettes on the corner what do
you think he's waiting for he's waiting
for [ __ ] Flaco to show up like where
the [ __ ] are you [ __ ]
alright I'll be here mad flavor bright
and early
1800 if you can see it already out there
look at it [ __ ] look at this lady from
[ __ ] zaboo look at it running across
the street with a purple outfit on what
do you think if I had the balls if I had
the [ __ ] balls idea [ __ ] we're
back [ __ ] mad flavor world just
giving you a taste of my morning early
mornings this is what I do I get up I
[ __ ] go over to the thing look he
must have [ __ ] detente you guys go
with him vote for me we're here my
favorite store Target so here we are
we're tied broccoli soup who the [ __ ]
would eat broccoli super target this is
I'm talking about so we're here look at
these [ __ ] people here look at this
beauty here with colored socks
oh you second like this I get Alibaba
here the [ __ ] is this him
that's his target welcome to it all
different nationalities people look at
least now how was a teenage [ __ ] Momo
one shorts on and [ __ ] what are you
gonna do counts like I've gotten that
they lose their [ __ ] mind I don't
have it
when I left the house I promised I'd
give him cabinet
this guy without [ __ ] rule on Mars or
some [ __ ] Oh 50 cents price grunt on
fancy fries I got it for 47 aroud she is
slipping [ __ ] Oh [ __ ] for the cat
littlez out here I usually find this
stuff no problem my babies if I come
home without the catnip is on the
argument people over yelling screaming
why you cover for [ __ ] cabinet with
this [ __ ] this is a cat [ __ ]
them they lose their [ __ ] mind lift
that ass the wind's blowing
she's ventilating what hit North
Hollywood parking lot is my favorite
place to see you [ __ ] whackadoo 'he's
here
it's 818 look at this guy I should be
doing [ __ ] running look at that guy
Tarzana looters got ya here right
[ __ ] great I love this [ __ ]
neighborhood I love I love it I [ __ ]
love it there's people living at the
park your karate with the brothers only
black people get up early and teach
[ __ ] martial arts that's it you know
why cuz they're [ __ ] savages that's
why you give a [ __ ] about what's going
on here
this poor guy look at this chick we're
living in California take the hood off
[ __ ] look at this lady right good
there's the YMCA my second [ __ ] home
I love that place that'll [ __ ] around
there look at this guy link Tina Orange
[ __ ] Carly ticket she thinks he get
look it's getting funny last week didn't
see him on the video and it wasn't
because I don't want to put him up it
was because he was reneging cuz he
wanted a [ __ ] piece of him and should
be looking fanny what you want some damn
[ __ ]
huh you want some ham you little
[ __ ] all right
they'll do anything for him but now you
gotta be on the show this week so I'm
gonna hear not a peep out of you goddamn
out when I told you I was gonna get
personal with you [ __ ] I told
you I wasn't personal my balls all
scrunched up right now I'm in the little
bathroom this is the private one on the
side I am two bathrooms
got the big one and my wife uses and
stuff like that and I got the one for me
called the [ __ ] explosive bathroom
this is what goes down before I go to
bed using a lot of fruits in the morning
it just looks like a little [ __ ]
muffler you know I'm saying and I come
in here what I do is one of the cats
comes in to say hello to me and I drop
my bomb and look you know now what
[ __ ] I told you at the bottom
he's over there trying to [ __ ] tap out
because he can't take it in here I
usually bring a candle in hand a bowl
torch and [ __ ] like that
but I seen him coming out and even have
a time to go to Campbell so I closed the
door now he's locked in here this is
fear factor right here get locked in
with a cabinet he's tapping out right
now he's like that I can't take it it's
like [ __ ] forget about it but we're
here I told you mad flavors world I'm
taking a little poopy and that's how I
wrote look at him he's down here [ __ ]
hitting [ __ ] what's up [ __ ] how
you like me now
[Music]
you